[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the senior
associate editor at the new statesman
rachel kunlev and the sons political
editor harry cole great to see both of
you so to the front pages then let's
start with the i which is there are
disagreements among liz truss's camp of
supporters some of whom are said to
believe she's not doing enough to tackle
the cost of living crisis
the guardian has seen analysis
suggesting that mistrust's tax plans
would cost 50 billion pounds to
implement but wouldn't do enough to help
those worst affected by the issue
well with host pipe bands projected to
last until october the telegraph reports
that this year will be the driest since
1976 amid drought conditions
the metro leads with the first day of
the trial of the former football of ryan
giggs he's accused of assault and of
coercive and controlling behavior he
denies the charges the star quoting from
the prosecution's opening remarks in
that trial
and likewise it is also the big story
for the sun
well a reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of from those newspapers while you
watch us but let's bring in our guests
now rachel cunliffe and harry cole more
papers coming in have to say perhaps a
little bit late with the news of olivia
newton john but let's some kick off
harry with the eye shall we um tensions
in liz trusses camp over her offer on
the cost of living and what is she
offering is it enough and will it change
um
yes it almost certainly will change i've
been
banging on for for days it feels like
now almost weeks that neither of the two
candidates are
really grappling with the size of the
problems that are going to be in their
interest should they win on september
5th um a winter discontent is something
of an understatement when you look at
some of the predictions of the size of
bills um and the energy price cap
reaching 3 400 3 700 pounds some people
will say and the difference literally
between heating and eating for millions
of people across this country i think
both the candidates are slowly realizing
that actually um you know rishi sunax
v80 on energy bills suspension for a
year saving 160 pounds dropping the
ocean not going to touch the sides same
for perhaps liz trusses um cut to knicks
which will save the someone earning the
median wage i think about 170 pounds
a year
none of this really is going to be
enough so there's been lots of
mudslinging over the weekend about who
will do more or what what what that
might be we'll be hearing a lot more
from richie souneck on this tomorrow but
there's a sort of sort of dawning
realization on his camp i think that
he's no longer the chancellor and if he
really wanted to make all these changes
perhaps he should have stuck around in
government whereas liz trust is saying
well in the long term handouts can't be
a sustainable answer but in the short
term the reality means that people need
a bailout and they're going to need a
big one this year yes and uh mr sunic
expected to say this winter is going to
be extremely tough for families up and
down the country and there is no doubt
in my mind that more support will be
needed as you said he could have been
the person to put that into place
question is who is now focusing on it uh
we know a few of them were off on
holiday last week rachel are they back
now and yet there will still be
no sense of an emergency budget or
planning or cobra or banging of heads
together or is it happening behind the
scenes and if it's behind the scenes
then perhaps the optics are now that we
need to see it happening
yeah i think the optics of this really
weren't great to have the prime minister
off on his delayed related
mini honeymoon
at the same time as the chancellor was
also off and the chief secretary to the
treasury was also on holiday now i i am
very much in the camp that says that
ministers do a very difficult job and
work very hard throughout the year and
they do deserve their holidays too
however one kind of feels that at this
particular moment facing this sort of
summer crisis especially since the prime
minister is not going to be the prime
minister in four weeks time maybe it
would have been uh smart at least from a
pr position if nothing else to delay
that that holiday by a couple of weeks
just so it didn't feel like this was the
country facing a crisis with no one in
control now i i also understand of
course boris johnson is a caretaker
prime minister he said that he
in the while the leadership contest is
going on he wouldn't make any major
legislative changes which is exactly the
role that he should be playing
but there are things that he could be
doing he could be working with both of
the candidates and their team so that
whoever is prime minister doesn't start
from from scratch on day one could be
preparing the groundwork uh and also
could be sort of offering a message to
the country that
this government does understand how
serious this crisis is and up until this
point really i think up until the last
couple of days that sense that the
government and the candidates get it
has been lacking now maybe that's an
unfair thing to say maybe there has been
a lot of work going on behind the scenes
but we haven't seen it and we haven't
really felt it
so to the guardian then harry um liz
trust's emergency tax and spending
pledges could cost upwards of 50 billion
pounds a year experts warning it will
fail to help the worst off deal with the
rising cost of living you know famously
tax cuts don't necessarily help
pensioners for example uh the times
which we'll get shortly two has um
dominic raab suggesting that trust's
plan is an electoral suicide note and
have people made their minds up those
who are voting for our next prime
minister or will this make an impact
i think the noise is off um from the
from the sunac campaign would suggest
they are getting increasingly desperate
doubling
i remember i'm old enough to remember
three or four weeks ago when he was
suggesting that he is
oh so important and definitely not made
up because he was fired as foreign
secretary appointment as deputy prime
minister meant he had to stay above the
fray he wouldn't be weighing in and
getting his hands dirty uh in this
campaign because he has such an
important constitutional role and here
he is getting down in the gutter uh and
suggesting that um a tax cut would um
would be electoral doom which is a bit
odd because tonight there's a poll from
redfield and wilton as a polling company
which shows that liz trusts actually the
one offering tax cuts immediately rather
than in seven years time is actually
beating kia stammer in the polls and
would you know and rishi sunak would not
beat kirsten look a lot of this is a
very conflicted august row i do think
this this leadership campaign has gone
on perhaps a little bit too long i think
they probably could have done it in four
weeks rather than eight um but no one
seemed to want to ruin their their
august holidays by doing a transition
and a handover of power in the middle of
august rather than when everyone was
back in september there's gonna be a lot
of slightly sort of hollow mud slinging
for the next
for the next um sort of four weeks but
rachel's absolutely right remember when
boris johnson was ousted at the
beginning of july there was a moment
where it looked like he might actually
the party might actually move against
him
um and actually force him out
immediately the sort of automatic
objection so to speak and actually no
the you know there's a wiser hands came
about there's a 1922 committee said
actually no let's do this with some
dignity he won't make any major policy
announcements and now the very same
people are screaming that you know they
were worried that boris johnson would
use his last months uh last month in
power to do things they didn't like and
now saying he's not doing anything a
cobra meeting isn't going to make the
blindest bit of difference what will
need to be done is an emergency budget
whoever wins in september where both
candidates need to admit really that
they have to get real on the size of the
problem yeah absolutely you know a
confected august row but it's real life
is it not for for
for real people nothing's gonna change
nothing's gonna change in the next three
weeks with a lame duck prime minister a
chancellor who knows he's not gonna be
the chancellor in the next couple weeks
actually
it would be easy if anything they should
expediate the leadership election but
that's not gonna happen but i don't
think anything fundamentally is going to
change without a budget and only a new
prime minister and a new chancellor will
have that sort of renewed mandate to
actually make these decisions yes indeed
and it's it's gordon brown who was the
first to say
come on get on with it everybody um you
know nobody is at the wheel is the way
the metro puts it um does does does
labor need to come out and and start
fighting on this as well or we just in
the sort of the august doldrums when
people are on holiday and drifting in
and out and you know everyone's sitting
there i mean people people are literally
working out how to get their hands on
sleeping bags so they don't have to turn
the gas boiler on aren't they you know
you know come come the winter
well i think you're what you're saying
about a labor policy vacuum is exactly
right we have had an opposition party
put forward a radical policy on energy
bills today it's it's ed davey and the
liberal democrats and he's called for
what he calls energy bill furlow which
is effectively for the government to
cancel the increase in the energy cap
and to absorb the cost that the full 36
billion cost uh partly through an
increased windfall tax and partly
through general taxation um that's quite
a smart move i think just in terms of
pr calling it
energy bills furlough people understand
what that means after the pandemic and i
think people kind of got used to drink
over to the idea that when there was a
really big national crisis the
government could step in they could do
absolutely unprecedented things like
lockdown but also like putting the tax
system into reverse which was what
furlough was they could find the money
for mass testing mass vaccination
rollouts we did incredible things in
order to
combat a a major national crisis and i
think there really is a sense up and
down the country that we are facing
another crisis a different crisis now
this winter with energy bills and with
the cost of living crisis and there is
bewilderment as to
why the government
hasn't committed to stepping in yet and
indeed what the heck do they have
they already have we've already spent 40
billion pounds
this year bailing people out the you
know this idea of a furlough 2.0 it's
going to be another 36 billion pounds on
top of the 400 billion pounds we've
already spent on covid at some point and
this is where i have some sympathy with
sunak is that someone has to stand up
and go hang on who is paying for this
you know are we actually going to
bankrupt the country because everyone's
got a taste of the idea that
when the going gets tough that instant
reaction is
it is a government bailout at some point
you know we've already people already
getting 1 200 pounds
from the government directly in handouts
what what point do you actually so so
the energy furlough idea of ed davey is
he's saying that everyone should get
sort of another another 450 pounds but
then why are we using that system such a
blunt tool to give people who can easily
afford a raise in energy bills money
that they don't need it seems slightly
mad i think it's gonna be a bit a bit
dully post covid than that
massive government spending is the
answer and i completely take that point
and i think that's a very legitimate way
of looking at it but you asked uh you
know at what point do we say it's enough
unfortunately even with the support that
has been offered and it was offered
before the price cap increased by 500
pounds you are going to see children
going hungry and anna mentioned
pensioners a moment ago in terms of
people who a tax cut wouldn't
necessarily help there are more children
in poverty in this country than there
are pensioners many of them in
households whose benefits are not going
up in line with inflation who are not
helped by the tax system so is the new
prime minister prepared to see children
starve is she prepared to see uh are
they prepared
this is the debate that's incredibly
unhelpful
because you make it you make it you make
it so binary in black and white that if
you don't do if you're not doing
anything you're letting children starve
but actually the most effective thing
you can do is targeted support which is
actually what is happening now which is
that actually people that most need it
are getting the most money everyone's
getting 150 quid off their council tax i
believe there's a 400 energy pound
rebate
but actually the people that really need
the money are getting the most of it
it's idea for med david that you can
have this blanket scheme where everyone
gets money just seems bonkers to me i
wasn't advocating for a davey's scheme
raciality i was just pointing out that
it was on the table and it was more
radical than anything that either of the
two candidates had so far proposed but
there is a there's a big difference
between letting children starve as you
so emotionally put and giving everyone
free cash right
rachel's being which should be good she
can she can hear my vibe that we need to
stop there apologies we will we will no
doubt talk about it but later on i was
just going to show the times as well
which is just dropped it also has some
of the figures that sunac's talking
about um the uh every house will get 400
pounds off their energy bills those are
means tested benefits would receive a
further 650 sources close to sunax
saying his priority would be to increase
support for the most vulnerable there's
also likely to be an increase in the 400
pound universal payment so those were
some of the figures harry that you were
mentioning there but we've got lots more
still to come including the sad news too
from the world of entertainment tonight
the actress and singer olivia
newton-john has died we will pay tribute
to her next
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview we are joined once again
by rachel cunliffe and harry kohlberg
and back to both of you um well weather
related matters rachel you kick off the
daily telegraph the driest year since
1976 drought looms we've been told that
for a few days now haven't we and
meantime
in related but slightly different
matters um a flood of all floods on your
road rachel
not quite my road but certainly around
the corner from from my house uh burst
water pipe uh the road is several feet
under water damage to many of the houses
some children who had to get rescued by
firefighters who were stuck in an
apartment block um thames water
is trying to to fix the problem but i
think the juxtaposition of these two
stories together the
we're kind of due to go into drought
over the next few days there's been
little no rainfall in parts of the
country since uh for 144 days um and a
lot of the water companies are telling
people to conserve water there are hose
pipe vans in some parts of the country
and then you look at just how much water
is lost through leakages every single
day i think 3 billion liters the
equivalent of a thousand
uh olympic-sized swimming pools thames
water loses admits on its website that
it loses a quarter of the water that it
handles um
and you kind of think
okay this is a massive crisis here but
there are structural issues here too
everyone could do their bit but maybe
it's not all about hose pipes yes well i
mean you know a lot of people like to
raise the
the leakage issue but you you would hope
that at some point we can have a
government that future proofs itself
harry but it feels like we're fighting
fires left right and center and we have
been for years now um you know
we need to really think about it don't
we
it was just
just a country that
have not been good at two things one we
haven't been very good at at hot weather
or indeed cold weather and did wind i
remember not old enough to remember
four or five months ago when it got a
bit windy and they tell us all stay at
home we just know a country that's very
bad at
weather and we're also very country
that's very bad actually flogging off
our national assets and privatizing
things and they're not really holding a
rod over those those privatized assets
to make sure they actually don't take
the mech anymore and actually do things
properly um the water companies being a
great example of that and the energy
companies again being a fantastic
example that the the profits we saw uh
in in recent recent days um you know it
all chimes into just a general sense of
this is a government that's been around
a little bit too long it's lost its
teeth maybe perhaps you know some people
need to come in and start cracking the
whip a bit or they let the other guys
have a game we've got um just 30 seconds
now on olivia newton john not
surprisingly her face all over the
newspapers rachel the sad news today
very very sad um absolutely
iconic uh i like the vast majority of
viewers known for grease but i've been
reading up on her since the news broke
and i've been reading about her
phenomenal work as an activist for
cancer research and better cancer
treatment and really one of those people
who had a celebrity platform and has
properly used it to try and change lives
so yes incredibly sad news
rachel harry thank you both very much
indeed there with the news that olivia
newton-john has died at the age of 73.